hey everybody welcome back to Jaeger
horn it's been quite a while since the
last episode but recently I've been
feeling pretty inspired to work on this
and I finally have some time to work on
this as well so if all goes well I
should be releasing uploads at a
slightly better upload rate than I have
been doing recently and if you follow me
on Twitter which you totally should by
the way if you're not doing that yet I'm
posting quite a few updates over there
as well of what I'm doing in this park
which means that you can see my stuff
before it goes up here on YouTube so
yeah this episode is basically about the
transfer track which I'm not going to
talk about too much because I have done
some videos on transfer tracks in the
past so I don't think I'll need to
explain the concept too much but there
are a few basic things which I kind of
want to talk about because essentially
what it boils down to is in that almost
every single aspect of this transfer
track I decided to make it look nice in
the first place and then figure out
afterwards how to actually make it
functionally sound which made this whole
process a little bit complicated
even if I'm pretty glad with what the
end result looked like so first of all
the type of transfer track that I'm
using here is the type of transfer track
where you slide the entire track back
and forth with the train on it
which is pretty useful if you don't want
to have a bunch of switch tracks of the
other type which is where you have a
very small piece of track where you have
one part that is straight and one part
that is curved and you switch between
these two to get the training on another
rail and the whole point of getting the
Train on another rail or you know
transferring the train to another rail
is for one it is to store tracks or to
store trains when you're not using them
so in the case of a multi train right
like this one you don't always have to
use all of the trains because that's
quite expensive and if it's a very quiet
day you might as well just run one train
and get it over with and when you're
doing that you can always store the
Train in the transfer track and the
other use of the transfer track is
sometimes not always but very often
just as a general maintenance shed or
just to store them in any case because
when you're working on the trains or you
need to inspect them in the morning or
anything like that it can be quite handy
to have a separate area where you can
put them so yeah in this case I went for
a completely sliding track which means
that there's just one curve leading into
this transfer track and then you can put
the Train on the track here and slide it
to the side on these iron beams and then
bring over the other track and store
another train on it I did a little bit
of a brain fart I suppose in the fact
that there is only two tracks I guess
with a lot of work I can actually put
three tracks in the storage shed here
but what it essentially means is that
eventually because I'm using three
trains one of the trains is to stay on
the track itself at all times which is
not exactly an ideal situation
maybe I'll slightly change that in the
future but at least it's acceptable and
doable for now
it's just complicated to get around that
because I decided as you might be able
to see I'm already working on the on the
transfer shed which I'll get into a
little bit more in the future but I
decided to have this place in the middle
of the park kind of usually when you
have a transfer track on a roller
coaster the park decides to put it
somewhere that's kind of out of you or
if you're universal or Disney you hide
it super well in some of those parks I
can't even tell where the transfer track
is because usually they transfer track
is something that doesn't look very good
and it's a place which you don't want
guests to see in general so you kind of
tend to hide it and in this case I
decided to put it in the middle of the
park because I wanted the shed of the
transfer track it's actually part of the
scenery to be part of all of these
houses which you have over here to
establish an alpine village mood and
this kind of is slightly annoying and
challenging because a transfer track
especially the one which I'm using here
is in the first place something which
you need for technical reasons and in
this case it means that we have a bunch
of sliding track down there which means
that there's
no way to make a building here which is
not perfectly rectangular shaped the
transfer tract itself is just a
rectangular footprint and that cannot be
any pillars in the middle of that
footprint because the track needs to
slide over there which means that making
this into a nice-looking building even
though that was my intention from the
get-go
is kind of challenging because as anyone
who might have some experience in
Minecraft might be able to tell you it's
kind of difficult to build a perfectly
rectangular boxy building that doesn't
look very boring and flat and boring I
shouldn't have said boring twice dinner
but I guess it gets the point across
rectangular buildings are really boring
and you generally want to avoid those
there's just no way of getting around
that with this transfer track in the
middle of my park and the reason why I'm
not hiding it on the side of the park
like this in your Universal Park is
partly because I didn't want to do that
because that wouldn't that would make
the the footprints of jäger horn even
larger and I'm trying to cram this whole
ride into a as realistically small area
as I can while on the other hand if I
didn't put this building here I feel
this we just kind of be a dead end in
the park sure I could put some foliage
over here or maybe some simple
terraforming but that would be kind of
boring and wouldn't really give you
anything to look at and with this
building over here I feel it's just
something that in the general
composition of the park gives you
something really nice to look at
honestly Jaeger horn is probably the
project where I've put most effort into
the sight lines and into the general
composition of the area out of anything
that I've ever done in planet coaster
and even with this shed even though it
might seem very randomly placed I
thought about this a lot when it comes
to how it would look together with the
station building and so if you're
looking from the path that bridges the
cosa Trek and goes toward the station
building you can see this building along
with the station kind of in the distance
and I think that they make for a pretty
good-looking couple
that makes the whole area feel a little
bit more well
so yeah that's why I decided to turn the
transfer tract into more of a scenery
thing in the first place so yeah with
all of that said with me wanting to have
a transfer track right here for scenery
reasons well at the same time a transfer
tract is really annoying to turn into a
nice-looking building because it's
perfectly rectangular but because it's
there for scenery reasons I wanted to
make it look as good as possible
this whole situation is kind of
complicated even to talk about but what
it essentially boils down to is that I I
wanted to build a shed which is just the
pure skeleton of a regular maintenance
shed some pillars on the sides and then
just a flat roof with a lot of beams
just as a sort of structural core to
make sure that this thing doesn't
collapse onto itself and then just build
all of the roofs in different variations
and different shapes with a lot of
detailing on top of that to kind of
distract you from the fact that this is
really in essence a perfectly
rectangular very boring storage shed so
yeah that's why you can see all of the
pillars on the side which are perfectly
supporting this building and you can see
the skeleton from the inside which is
just a very boring rectangular skeleton
of a building as well but I'm trying to
add as many shapes and details around
that to get a nice looking building on
the outside I'm not going to put too
much effort into the interior yet
definitely not the interior of the
storage track itself but I do want to
put a lot of effort into making sure
that the skeleton of this building is
realistic because I wanted to make sure
that this would be able to realistically
be a decent looking transfer track even
if that doesn't make a lot of sense from
a park perspective it's something I just
really wanted to try in this case
so yeah with all that said with the
skeleton in place for the building all
that's really left to do is to finish
the detailing do a little bit of
interior not because there's gonna be
anything up here but because with this
balcony on fronts you'll be able to look
into the building so I at least want to
put a little bit of stuff here as a
little bit of an easter egg maybe in the
future I didn't do that in this episode
but it would be fun to maybe at some
point add some scenery objects in there
like some barrels or whatever as
something to at least gawk at when
you're looking at the building from the
outside but yeah it's a it's a slightly
weird situation because like I said
usually you have to eat when to drink
and it's sort of a hidden area but in
this case I made the decision to really
integrate it as much as I could into the
scenery of this whole park which is also
interesting because the building itself
the way it looks from the outside at
least was inspired by typical Alpine
townhouses that you see throughout the
Alps in Europe though is very Tyrolean
and Swiss little mountain houses and
that's also why I thought it would be
interesting to have these stucco fronts
where even though it's just one stucco
wall and it's not really a building in
itself because I can't really put any
walls in the middle of the trench at
rank because we have this lining track
there at least that little arched stucco
wall kind of gives you the impression of
this building being a regular Alpine
house and then all of the the varying
roof pitches and the wooden pillars that
you have on the side give a sense of
variation into how the building looks
now if that all said this building is
almost finished I'll be getting back to
it a few times in the future just to add
more detail to it again and make it look
slightly better but the rest of this
episode is also some detailing when it
comes to foliage around the ride itself
and obviously I still need to finish all
of the catwalks because that's something
that I started at at some point in the
past
and now I'm kind of regretting it but I
kind of need to add all of the catwalks
around the right as well just in case
that it stops somewhere along the ride
so that you can evacuate the people and
make sure that they walk to the to the
rest of the park kind of in the same way
that people tend to get evacuated on Big
Thunder Mountain which column I'm
jealous of people who actually get
evacuated on that it's kind of funny
because sometimes Big Thunder Mountain
manages to stall in the middle of the
ride and they have to walk down the
catwalks that run alongside the track
which for a lot of people is just you
know something funny in your day but for
a lot of coastal enthusiasts that is
like a big wish like a lot of people
really want to get stuck on a roller
coaster and get evacuated as if it's
some kind of achievement which I always
thought it's funny I would definitely
love to be evacuated one day
unfortunately it's never happened to me
so far but it would definitely be a fun
experience at least on this poster you
can walk your way back into the park
there's a lot of courses where if you
get stuck somewhere Midway it's gonna
take a pretty complicated evacuation
thing to get everybody out of there
right again but yeah that is that is way
off topic in any case that's why I
decided to have all of the catwalks
alongside the ride which I still have to
keep doing every time that there is a
section of the ride which doesn't have
them yet there's also a few Alpine
touches to this building by the way
which I definitely think do kind of sell
the Alpine European look there's again
the painted decorations on the side of
the walls here I didn't want to leave
the walls completely empty and I think
these sort of squishy swirly paint
decorations and a neat flare to the
building then there's the little spires
on top of the cables or really a a sort
of Swiss Chalet kind of addition the
same goes for all of the wooden beams
which decorate the cables still a big
fan of adding those and with every
building that I add I'm still trying to
have some slight variations in
in gables and then there is a large
storm er over here because this area
really felt kind of empty and I felt
like adding a dormer here would neatly
finish the building when it comes to the
composition and add a bit of detail to
the roof here and then of course there's
also all of the flower window boxes
which are just those things that you see
all throughout the European Alps which
definitely add a nice natural flair to
the building because as any architect
that does any renders probably knows
adding foliage to a building just always
makes it look better and if you add a
lot of foliage to your buildings you
might even win a skyscraper award even
though your building doesn't look that
great but it just has a lot of foliage
on it mm-hmm that's that's I'm not
throwing any shade there by the way I do
like it the honestly though the problem
with a lot of architectural renders when
it comes to buildings though is that on
the renders they'll have a lot of
foliage on it but then in real life the
foliage is kind of lackluster
and in a lot of countries like the
Netherlands where they keep trying this
thing these buildings look nice and
summer but then when it's winter and all
of the foliage is losing their leaves it
looks kind of mediocre and then you'd
rather wish that all of the attention
went to designing the building itself
that's wildly off-topic but I can kind
of relate it back to planet coaster
because one thing that I always feel is
kind of surprising about planet coaster
is that nobody does any winter coasters
maybe if you people have done this but
I've rarely seen it and sure people make
coasters where it's in a snowy biome but
I mean winter as in when it's winter
when a park is running in winter and
there's not necessarily any snow but all
the trees are dead and lifeless and
everything just looks generally very
different there's barely any grass and
the grass that is there it looks a
little bit more colorless overall
there's very few colors I think it's a
style which a lot of people don't do
because it obviously looks really drab
but with a lot of theme parks in the
world being open all year round yet in
winter having very colorless foliage and
very different look altogether I think a
winter park in general could be very
interesting and planet coaster and again
I'm not talking about winter in terms of
snow I think plenty of people are trying
to snow a biome but really just winter
in terms of how most places that are not
an anoxic climates or a tropical climate
look like in winter when there's not any
snow but yeah that is still a little bit
of an off topic points it's soo
something and something that I think
about sometimes because you know this is
planet coaster we can basically present
the perfect situation but all planet
coaster parks almost all of them are
always perfectly vibrant and saturated
and all of the trees have all of their
leaves and everything it's always sunny
and beautiful weather but most of the
times theme parks don't actually look
like this this is a sort of very
idealistic image of what a theme park
looks like him that that is not really
throwing any shade to anybody really
just an idea I would love to sometime
see some real winter parks or some kind
of drab looking parks where it just
gives you a cozy winter atmosphere I
think there's some charm to that as well
being in a park where the weather is
kind of bad and all the trees are kind
of dead but it's quiet and you can drink
hot chocolate sometimes that's really
awesome as well it's about time by the
way that I start getting on topic again
I don't think I've quite pointed this
out yet this is the second time that I'm
recording the commentary so I think I
only pointed it out in the Pew in the
previous time but the back of the
building here is in the sort of standard
storage shed style normally if you have
a transfer tract this is just usually
what you'd see just dressing up the
skeleton with some very simple and cheap
walls and no detailing at all and that
is what I'm doing at the back of this
building just because there will be
foliage around here plus there are no
sight lines here there's no path
anywhere near this and you're not gonna
be able to see this so I don't really
see the point's interesting this up all
too much just keeping the back of the
maintenance shed here as simple as I can
just to make sure that realistically I
wouldn't have to spend too much money on
that
it's also a little bit lower than the
rest of the building so it certainly
doesn't draw any attention toward it and
the real focus of the building is really
toward the front of it now something
which I totally forgot to talk about
which I just did a little while ago is
do the other part of the transfer tract
because there is one thing which I
didn't need to build to make sure that
you can get the cosa train either on the
track itself or onto the transfer track
is that little switch track right in
front of the station usually you see
those switch tracks behind the station
or at the end of the ride if you will
but in this case this is really the only
place where I could fit it but that
switch track is really just the more
standard type of switch track and what
you typically see on mine train coasters
as well where there's just one small
straight piece of track and one curved
one and you switch between these two to
lead the coaster train down to different
paths
usually it switches horizontally like
this sometimes they actually have a
rotating one where both tracks are on
the bottom of each other and it's kind
of like flipping a coin but yeah there's
a bunch of variations on this but this
is just the one that fits best in here
and the only one that I honestly have to
space the build and the rest of this is
just kind of finishing the last little
details on the shed adding some foliage
around it and also finishing that little
lake that we've got going in the middle
of this whole area which i think is
shaping up to be a pretty good part for
some sight lines as well
I'm trying to keep the sightlines in
mind as much as possible throughout the
building of this whole ride and one of
my favorite sight lines is honestly from
the catwalks of that little lake you
only see it for a fraction of a second
if you're on the ride itself because
even though it curves around that sight
line you'd obviously have to tilt your
head quite a bit to see the view but I
still think it's a really cool view and
something which would look really great
if you do manage to look that way if
you're on the coaster because it it is
not one of you where all the bridges
line up where you can see the station as
well as the church in the distance and
hence why I decided to have a lake there
just to make sure that that sight line
is intact because if there were just
regular foliage and trees over there you
would definitely not be able to have
that sight line so yeah sometimes I go
for a a feature in the landscape just to
make sure that you can see something
else from some other place which I think
works out in some cases in any case for
Jaeger horn the sight lines are some of
the most important parts of the park now
finally I wanted to round up this
episode by finishing this wall of
foliage on the side of the track here
just to make sure that you don't see the
edge of the park and you don't see that
wooden fence that separates the park
from the staff area and that is
basically it for this episode and that
is the transfer tract and its
surroundings finished I'd like to thank
you guys for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]